actually somebody who sat down to have a
debate with you
three years later didn't really like the
way that he came across so now he wants
you to remove your video otherwise are
gonna punish you by the way pedophiles
Channel still have to be put there seven
awesome queens first let me provide some
context you YouTube is actually filed a
privacy violation notice for our male
privileges a myth changed my mind video
and here's thing I'm not above admitting
when I or anyone the team is made a
mistake but YouTube's suggested videos
alongside it we're a bit questionable
you think it so we actually got this a
notice in the mail that said someone has
declared us to be a privacy violation
right okay on YouTube and all it lists
is about four or five time codes and
there are five people who appear
throughout all of those time codes this
is by the way a video that we do this
was a video it's changed my mind so we
sit down have a civil dialogue with
people with whom we disagree there's a
camera and a camera in a can't like no
one is walking him couldn't be more
obvious people consent to being on
camera and Texas is a single party
consent state where this one was
performed with no reasonable expectation
of privacy in a public location so they
just want to say they just want us to
blur everything out yeah this is the law
it's not about it's not about security
it's not about harassment or abuse
it's not even obeying single party
consent land I understand you YouTube's
a private platform they say they can do
whatever they want but there has to be
some semblance of a business contract or
we can say okay well hold on a second in
state of Texas is what we can film it's
what we can't film on they go well
actually somebody who sat down to have a
debate with you
three years later didn't really like the
way that he came across so now he wants
you to remove your video otherwise our
gonna punish you by the way pedophiles
Channel still have to be better seven
awesome please well don't they have to
go by the state laws on this legitimate
question right so if it's a single party
consent state for me to have a
legitimate gripe with any company to
pull something down or make you adjust
the content doesn't it have to be within
the law like I don't have to be able to
make no no it doesn't because they're
going a little bit further than the law
okay I guess if they weren't enforced in
the lowly over there saying well
actually I need to mate of consent is
twelve you know as they've many they
would like in Silicon Valley they can't
do that yeah what's interesting well
we're going a step further and even
anyone who signs can say even anyone who
is in a single party consents state if
they later on say actually I wish that I
hadn't we're gonna make you take it down
okay so how is the content creator how
can you possibly ever
anything and invest the money the time
and the energy and the resources to go
down and do something like this without
the fear of somebody just randomly
saying oh I don't like steven crowder
and I happened to walk by the whole
video has to come down or I'm suing
hot-wing reviews or pedophile channels
that's how the point is investigated the
investigative journalism has to be dead
yeah yeah it would have to be dead and
YouTube has their way it couldn't
possibly exist and what's important
about this too is these policies they
cater to people who will always use the
system for censorship not freedom this
is why conservatives that are
disadvantaged here because conservatives
don't go on and mass flag videos as hate
speech to get them Auto removed which is
what used to happen conservatives don't
go around and ask that videos be pulled
down because there were videotapes
showing up at a public protest some
people have but not on mass these
policies always cater to the worst most
anti freedom among us and if you try to
reach out to YouTube to fix it we said
hey listen who's complaining oh we don't
know what the time codes don't even make
any sense you have one that's twenty
minutes in they have one that says zero
minutes in and they have 24 seconds and
so what do we actually change I don't
know what do we need to blur I don't
know all the direct all enquiries to the
child banging wind to the bang at Google
support calm why there are so many
pedophiles by the way in the
entertainment story and you do it's like
it's coming no it's because you've got
rid of their natural predators
conservative fathers that's right
conservatives are the pedophiles what
garlic is to vampires okay we are the
people out there who want we want to
actually enforce the law yeah and we
actually want channels where people who
are actually engaging in pedophilia to
be removed not dema but you don't
demonetized a person because i had a
civil dialogue with someone on a
pompadour who started screamin the check
is privileged this video watch another
one of our videos or subscribe at the
notification bail those don't really
mean anything anymore today in youtube i
would say hit a like with a thumbs up
but that might be gone or comment below
but that most likely will be censored so
bookmark the page of course if you're
using google chrome they'll find a way
to [ __ ] with your bookmark so just join
up at la doors credit comm slash moncla
that's a lot of credit calm slash mug
club you get a hand at schmuck and you
get access to the full daily one-hour
show and you're not beholden to Susan
jiske slash Clint Howard